Narrator:
For over a decade,
"Shark Tank" has been at
the forefront of innovation...
The doorbell has not changed
since it was invented in 1880.
Our mission is to help Americans
eat better.
Scrub Daddy will be scrubbing
in every kitchen in the world.
Narrator:
...showcasing America's
most ingenious products
and trend‐setting ideas.
‐There you go. [ Laughs ]
‐Whoo‐hoo!
Narrator: And tonight,
branding expert Rohan Oza
returns to the Tank.
We would be willing
to give you guys $1 million.
Greiner: Whoa.
Just when you think
you've seen it all...
Man: Whoo!
...there's always something new
coming in the Tank.
Which of these companies
will be the next big idea?
Let's get started!
Narrator:
The future starts now.
Herjavec: Wow!
First into the Tank
is a way to bring some sunshine
into your life.
♪♪
Hi.
My name is Amber Leong,
and I'm seeking $750,000...
Whoa.
...in exchange for 10% of
my company, Circadian Optics.
Wow.
Sharks, close your eyes
and imagine you're inside
a dark, windowless room.
Now open your eyes
and picture yourself outside
on a bright, sunny morning
with sun in your eyes.
Since the beginning of time,
the sun has risen in the morning
and set in the evening.
This is the cycle
of life itself.
Just like diet and exercise,
light is vital to our physical
and mental health.
We used to spend all day hunting
and foraging outside,
but today, all of us slog away
inside a dark office all day.
We're not getting enough light.
This is disrupting
our body clock
and is making us tired
and unhealthy.
But what if there was a way
we could bring the sun
right to your desk?
Now you can
with Circadian Optics.
We make
bright‐light therapy lamps
that mimic the color
and the brightness of the sun.
Using this for minutes...
Whoa.
...will help set your body clock
for the day ahead.
It's a mini sun on your desk.
Sharks, help us bring more light
into people's lives.
Who's ready to turn on their day
with Circadian Optics?
And what was your inspiration
behind this?
So, I'm originally
from Malaysia,
but I currently live
in Minnesota.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, boy.
That's where
you got the accent.
That explains ‐‐ Right there,
you've given me the answer.
In Minnesota, you see the sun
six months out of the year.
But because I was working
at a corporate job,
I didn't see the sun
12 months of the year,
and the lack of light was really
affecting my health.
I was feeling sluggish at work,
I couldn't sleep at night...
Interesting.
...and I realized the importance
of circadian rhythm and light.
So I bought
a light‐therapy lamp.
I felt better
in a couple of days,
but the problem was my coworkers
would tease me endlessly
because of the design of it.
It was this big
white fluorescent lamp
that took a lot of space
on my desk.
It made me look like
the crazy person in the office.
[ Laughs ]
I get it.
So, there was the gap
in the marketplace
for a light‐therapy lamp
that is effective,
but at the same time stylish.
You're putting a real valuation
on the table, right?
Yes.
You're saying, "My company's
worth $7.5 million,"
and therefore,
you must have blockbuster sales.
I do.
My lifetime sales
is $7.4 million.
Good for you.
Oh, I hate
lifetime sales, though.
What about
the last 12 months?
Can you give me
annual sales, please?
Last year,
I sold $4 million.
Wow.
That's fantastic.
Thank you!
Are all of
your sales online?
All of our sales
are online.
What is
your average sale online?
Average sale is $57.99.
And what are
your margins, Amber?
My margin is 70%.
Whoa.
So you got to be
making money
hand over foot.
Wow.
I have been doing okay,
but I have ‐‐
No, but ‐‐ So if you have
70% margin,
you're selling
all online...
Mm‐hmm.
...either you have
ungodly returns
or something really wrong.
So, last year,
I made $652,000.
What's this year
gonna be?
This year, I'm projected
to do $5.6 million.
What are you gonna make
on the $5.6 million?
I'm going to make $1.3 million
with the tariffs accounted for.
So you're making
20%‐plus margins per take?
Yes, 25%.
Why do you need
a Shark?
Yeah, so, I am here
because I am looking for
a strategic partner
that can help take my company
to the next level.
Right now,
I'm a $5 million company,
and I sell only online.
That might be
a good thing.
If I want to go into retail,
and it's a different ‐‐
it's such
a different ballgame ‐‐
I want it to be worth the work.
Amber,
what is your backstory?
My personal background.
So, I'm originally
from Malaysia.
I grew up pretty poor.
I actually ‐‐
the house that I lived in
didn't have indoor plumbing,
but I always had the dream
of coming to America.
I think too many episodes
of "Full House."
Mm.
And when it was time
to go to college,
I told my parents
I wanted to come to America,
and they said,
"Okay, let's do this together."
They cashed out
their retirement fund,
they borrowed money
from their family and friends
to send me to school here
on a one‐way ticket
and school fees
and living expenses
for one semester.
But they gave everything
they could to me,
so, like, that is how much faith
they have in me.
[ Voice breaking ] Um...
♪♪
Nine months after
coming to America,
I was diagnosed
with toxic shock syndrome.
I was given
a 50% chance of surviving,
but my parents couldn't come
because they didn't have
an American visa.
But I ‐‐ I survived.
And that was a ‐‐ a gift.
It gave me
a new perspective in life,
and it made me ask myself,
"What am I going to do with
my one wild and precious life?"
So I went to grad school,
I got a six‐figure job,
and I gave back.
I send money home,
and when I have enough savings,
I ask myself, "I want to do
something courageous.
I have to take a chance."
[ Sniffles ]
So, I had this idea,
and I need to choose creativity
over certainty.
And that drives and motivates me
every single day.
How lucky and blessed am I?
Great.
Wow.
Thank you.
You represent
why we all do this show.
to everybody in America...
The American dream.
...everybody around the world
that watches this show
that it doesn't matter
where you come from.
If you put
your mind to it,
anything is possible.
You represent everything great
about entrepreneurship,
the American dream.
You are freedom.
Thank you.
So, thank you
for sharing that with us.
That's just incredible.
No balls, no babies.
Amen, baby!
[ Laughter ]
To me,
with an entrepreneur,
if you look at
a field of dandelions,
do you see
a field of weeds,
a field of wishes?
Right?
I want
to invest in people
that see
a field of wishes,
and that's
who I think you are.
I would like
to help you...
Mm‐hmm.
...and to blow all your wishes
all over America, this product.
But I'd like
another Shark with me.
Okay.
Okay?
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Lori is interested
in Amber's light‐therapy
business, Circadian Optics,
but she wants to partner
with another Shark.
Greiner: I would like
to help you...
Mm‐hmm.
...and to blow all your wishes
all over America, this product.
Yes.
But I'd like
another Shark with me.
Okay.
Okay?
And I am looking
over at Mark.
♪♪
So, Mark,
would you be interested
in going in with me?
Yeah,
I'm open to it, for sure.
You would
go in with me?
Cuban:
Yeah, of course.
Well, why don't you hear
what it is first?
Okay, then Mark and I need to
have a conference for a moment.
Okay.
Cuban: So, what do you
want to do?
O'Leary:
If I give you $750,000
and I'm
an outside investor ‐‐
an investor,
I'm not an operator ‐‐
Mm‐hmm. Yep.
...how do
I get it back?
So, you will get it back
when we scale, so ‐‐
You mean
you're gonna give me
10% of distributions
when you pay yourself?
We will have that discussion,
but I'm open to that.
What do you need
the money for?
You seem
so self‐sufficient.
I'm wondering why
you need any help.
That $750,000,
we're gonna spend on inventory.
There are a lot of things
on social and dot‐com ‐‐
Okay,
we have an offer.
Yes. Yeah.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
And it's coming from
the boss.
Before they go in, then,
I think you're
an amazing human being.
Thank you.
Like,
your immigrant story,
I bond with
in a massive way.
I've taken risks,
but not the way you did
with your entire family's
background on the line.
Mm‐hmm.
So, I take my hat off
to you on that.
Thank you, Rohan.
But I'm not seeing,
honestly,
the value
that I could provide.
Okay.
I'm out.
Okay, got it.
Thank you.
Okay,
we'll put ‐‐
Barbara and I will put
our offer out first.
Okay.
All right?
Because I think we bring
a lot to the table.
Okay, I think Lori first,
'cause they discussed longer.
So, to be fair.
Greiner: Okay,
here's our offer.
Mark and I are gonna give you
the $750,000 for 20%,
'cause you got us both.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you for the offer.
Um...
Can I listen to Barbara's
and Kevin's offer? Okay.
We're gonna give you
exactly the same offer.
I look at this and say
we could probably help you
double your sales
very, very quickly
and probably
help you a lot
in your manufacturing
because I have
a lot of products.
We'll give
an extra $50,000
for your parents,
who are unbelievable people.
They would cry!
It's the same offer.
I don't know about
the parental thing.
Is that coming out of
the $750,000 they're giving you,
or are you giving them
an extra $50,000?
We'll give them
an extra $50,000.
♪♪
Amber, you have to decide.
No balls, no babies, right?
No balls, no babies!
[ Chuckles ]
So...
[ Sighs ] Okay.
I know I should negotiate,
be a good business partner,
but I am here for Lori and Mark,
both of you.
You have a deal!
Cuban: Yeah!
Aah! [ Laughs ]
Oh, my God!
That's awesome.
Oh, Lori, thank you!
Thank you so much.
Congratulations.
Thank you, Mark.
Thank you.
One of
the best presentations.
One of the best.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Congrats, Amber.
Thank you.
♪♪
[ Exhales sharply ]
Oh, my God!
I've never dreamed this big.
I'm just a girl
from a small town in Malaysia.
Oh, my God.
I went to the bathroom
in an outhouse,
and now I'm in L. A.
pitching to the Sharks.
If you have the chance
and the opportunity
to reach for your dreams,
reach for your dreams.
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 9,
Ashley Thompson and Kat Thomas
made a deal with Mark Cuban
for their overnight oats
product, Mush.
All natural,
100% ready‐to‐eat oatmeal.
Let's see how they're doing now.
Thompson: When we pitched
on "Shark Tank,"
we had had
about $200,000 in sales.
Now it's been
a year and a half,
and we've done
$5 million in sales.
Before "Shark Tank,"
we were in 150 retail doors.
Now we're in
over 3,500 nationwide,
like Whole Foods,
Publix, Wegmans, ShopRite,
and even Walmart.
But successes come with
some challenges.
When I pitched on "Shark Tank,"
it was me
and my co‐founder, Kat,
but she had to step away
from the business
due to some really serious
health issues.
I feel like there's more weight
on my shoulders
now that she's gone.
♪♪
[ Voice breaking ] It's been
really tough losing Kat.
She'll always be a founder
and still has equity,
but she's no longer
in the day‐to‐day business.
My biggest hurdle now is the
transition from founder to CEO.
Mark Cuban couldn't have come
at a better time.
It's not so much about
hiring people that you know.
It's about hiring people
who are best for the job.
Cuban:
What Mush has done
is really change
the overnight‐oats category.
It can be dessert,
it can be a meal,
and their consumers
are eating it up, literally.
We're doing all the right
things. I'm proud of you guys.
From $200,000‐some sales
to $5 million to $7 million
to $20 million,
this is a rocket ship,
and I'm glad to be part of it.
Thompson:
Just a few years ago, Kat and I
were working on Wall Street
and had this crazy idea to make
a better‐for‐you product.
Now we have
a multimillion‐dollar business,
and so my advice to anyone
is to start,
even if you don't know how.
You'll figure it out
if you have the drive
and you really believe in
the product that you're making.
Mush! Mush!
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a quick boost
of a life essential.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Rob Neuner.
I'm the CEO and founder
of Boost Oxygen.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Mike Grice.
I'm the Chief Operating Officer
of Boost Oxygen.
Oxygen is the most
essential element
for the heart, for the brain,
and for the muscles to function.
And we've all seen supplemental
oxygen being utilized
by professional football players
on the sidelines,
by aviators,
by mountaineers,
and by many other people
for many different purposes.
Boost Oxygen is 95%
pure aviator's breathing oxygen
compressed into affordable
and portable aluminum canisters.
It's an all‐natural product
for health and wellness,
but it's not
a medical device.
Our mission at Boost Oxygen
is to make compressed oxygen
as available
as bottled water.
And, Kevin, if we sucked all
the oxygen out of this room,
we'd all be literally
dead to you right now.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
So, sometimes
you want more.
We believe that
by partnering with one of you,
we'll be able to reach
millions of people
who want to improve
their quality of life
and their performance.
So,
what we're gonna do,
we're all gonna try the oxygen
at the same time.
So,
you take the mask,
you put it under the nose
and over the mouth,
and you press
the trigger.
Right over the top.
Inhale it
for a couple of seconds.
We're gonna all do it
at the same time.
So, you ready?
1, 2, 3. 1, 2, 3.
[ Canisters hissing ]
[ Chuckles ]
So,
what we're asking for
is a $1 million
capital investment ‐‐
[ Coughs loudly ]
[ Laughs ]
...for a 5% equity stake
in Boost Oxygen.
Oh! Okay.
Greiner:
Wait. Repeat that.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
I'm out.
[ Canister hisses ]
What are your sales?
This year will be
$6.4 million.
Ooh.
Greiner: Whoa.
Oh, my God.
And are you profitable?
Neuner:
We are profitable.
Grice: Yes.
In 2018,
we had $705,000 in net income.
And how much will you make
this year, you think?
This year, we're gonna make
about $1.5 million.
Okay. Really?
Who's using this?
It really started at
altitude 'cause it's
an intuitive product.
When you go up
from Florida to Vail
and you go skiing
and you're breathing hard,
you see oxygen, you're like,
"I'm gonna try that."
And you try it, and you like it.
You use it when you're there.
When you
go back to Florida
and you're breathing hard,
you're exercising,
any time
that you're breathing hard,
it's your body telling you
you need more oxygen.
Cuban: Okay,
so, talk about competition,
'cause I know the Mavs use
a different type of canister
than this.
Yeah.
We do have competitors,
but what we're trying to do
is we're trying to
create a new space, a new
market, a new vertical,
'cause there is no
oxygen vertical right now.
Yeah, very nice to hear,
but where do you rank
with your competitors?
We have roughly 95% market share
in the United States.
Whoa!
[ Canister hissing ]
So, what's the cost of this
to the consumer?
$14.99, $9.99, $7.99.
For the 2‐liter.
The cost is $2.05
to manufacture and aggregate
for all of
our different SKUs.
All of it?
How many hits do you get?
200 inhalations.
Is this FDA‐approved?
It's not FDA ‐‐
It's not a drug.
We're not regulated
by the FDA.
Oza: Someone here gives you
a million bucks, great.
Yes.
Now what are you gonna do
with that?
First thing we're going to do
is we need to expand our staff.
We would like to have greater
control over our sales force.
Right now,
we work with brokers,
we work with distributors,
we work with retailers.
O'Leary:
This is all retail?
Yeah.
You really want
to go to retail?
Yes.
Why not just stay the course
online and ‐‐
Sure.
'Cause what I'm worried about
is there'll be a lot of
delistings
in stores that don't turn
this stuff.
It's an impulse purchase.
♪♪
Oza: So, the problem
at the moment is,
the impulse purchase means
I'm on the mountain,
I feel like I need oxygen
or I'm out of breath,
I'm gonna impulse‐buy.
That's a decent market.
The great market are brands you
have to use on a routine basis.
Right.
Uh‐huh.
My concern is,
you're trying to educate people
on a problem they don't
really know they have.
And, so, unfortunately,
for that reason, I'm out.
Okay. Thanks.
Okay.
Yeah, appreciate it.
Sure.
Corcoran: I had an experience
with your particular brand
when I was in Utah
with my husband, Bill,
who has breathing issues.
I wholeheartedly agree with you
that you need to do retail
because I don't think
people take the time to think,
"Let me order a supply online."
But, as you've already learned,
it's a very expensive
proposition.
More importantly,
I saw a beach house last week
that was exactly $1 million,
and it was beautiful.
[ Chuckles ]
Uh‐huh.
What beach?
Oh, it was cheap,
and I'm not telling you,
'cause you'll probably try
to overbid me.
But here's the skinny ‐‐
I'd much rather
have that beach house
for the million dollars,
so I'm out.
Okay.
I appreciate it.
Even when I love people,
I don't always feel like
it's the right deal for me.
Love you.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
We appreciate it.
Guys, it's rare
that we have a company come on
that has
95% market share.
Just doesn't happen,
so congratulations.
But in looking at
the five of us,
none of us took it and said,
"Wow, this is a no‐brainer."
We all had to, like,
"Oh, wait, do I feel anything?"
That's not good.
Normally, I can come up
with an angle for anything
to get it on
a ubiquitous path.
I just ‐‐
I don't see it.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
I'm gonna make you an offer,
but before I do,
I want you
to take a big breath,
because you're gonna need it,
okay?
Let's do it together.
All right!
Oza: You're not gonna
like the number, and it's
not gonna be equity,
that's for sure.
I‐I feel better
about this offer
than I even felt
a few seconds ago.
So, here's what it is.
You have good cash flow
in this company,
so you can support
some debt.
I'm going to give you
the million bucks in a loan,
36 months ‐‐
3 years, okay?
9% interest,
and I want 7 1/2% equity.
Right.
The great thing
about being a Shark is,
every buyer
calls you back ‐‐ always.
So, that's an offer that I think
is a very good one for you,
'cause there's only one
Mr. Wonderful.
I don't know why
you wouldn't accept that.
I think it's a great offer.
Well, I'm still concerned
about taking on debt
when we don't need
to take on debt, especially 9%.
Um, so, what ‐‐
But you asked
for $1 million.
I have no choice
but to give you $1 million.
What does it matter
how you get it?
Neuner: It's more of
a buy‐in, though.
Wasn't really ‐‐
We don't need the cash.
We need someone
just to buy in ‐‐
Hey, guys,
no Shark up here
is gonna give you
a million bucks for 5%
because they never
get their money back
until there's an exit.
We don't know
when that's gonna happen.
You're allowed
to counter.
Greiner: Yeah.
Oza:
Or he'll pull it.
Okay.
What do you think?
I think
it's a very valid point.
Right.
So, uh, so we'll do
$1 million...
Yeah.
...uh, for, uh,
6% of the, uh ‐‐
not 6% ‐‐
6% is the, um ‐‐
sorry, the, uh,
interest rate, yeah.
6%.
The deal now
is you're countering me,
instead of giving me
9% interest,
you want to give me 6%.
Yes.
I keep my 7 1/2%,
right?
5%. For 5%.
5%.
All right,
because we're all reasonable,
we meet
in the middle.
[ Laughs ]
Okay. Split the baby.
That's how
we get this deal done.
So, I'm at 9%, you're at 6%.
Yeah.
7 1/2% interest,
no problem.
Cuban: Above 10%.
And 6% equity.
6 1/4%.
I'm pretty sharp
on the numberonis, there,
when we're cutting it
in half.
[ Laughs ]
I think the deal's reasonable.
Let's go.
Good?
♪♪
We'll take the deal.
Cuban: Lovely.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Thank you,
guys.
I like it.
Okay,
I appreciate it.
Thanks so much,
yeah.
Coupons.
He's clipping coupons.
Good luck.
Thank you.
Thank you
for your time.
Greiner:
Bye. Good luck.
You're gonna need it.
No, I'm kidding.
[ Laughter ]
‐That was good.
‐Yeah, that was good.
Grice: Quite honestly,
I was very surprised
to be shaking hands
with Mr. Wonderful
talking about
a million‐dollar deal,
and the input
that we received
from the entire
Tank of Sharks,
it's gonna do nothing
but take us
from good to great.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is what
the entrepreneur believes
is like a fountain of youth.
♪♪
Greiner: Ah.
Corcoran:
Wow. Great outfit.
Cool.
Ooh.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Koko.
I am asking $200,000
for 20% of the company.
In this day and age,
appearance is everything.
Sharks, what if I told you
you could look 10 years younger
without any plastic surgery
or injection?
I have found the fountain
of youth because I am...
61 years old.
♪♪
What?
Unbelievable.
Seriously?
I hate you.
I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
[ Laughter ]
I'm 40 years old.
[ Groans ]
I was like, "You would've got
five bids right there."
Oh, my God!
My business is Face Yoga.
[ Laughs ]
Face Yoga is
a really great natural solution
to regain your
youthful appearance.
Face Yoga.
We wake up
sleeping muscle in the face
to lift up your face
and relax
those overarching muscle
for wrinkle reduction.
So, Kevin, let's see your face
as of today.
Oh, let's not.
Corcoran: [ Laughs ]
You look great,
but if you do
Face Yoga exercises,
you can look like this.
Even more wonderful, right?
I love it.
[ Laughter ]
This is great.
O'Leary: Oh, my.
But if you don't do
any exercise,
you can look like this
just in a couple years.
[ All groaning ]
Nasty!
Cuban:
That's brutal.
Which would you like?
There's no way
I'm gonna look like that.
That ain't happening.
No, I'm serious.
I know.
I'm a Face Yoga expert.
So, Kevin, would you like
to come up here
so that I can make you look
10 years younger?
Yeah, sure.
Let's do
some exercises together.
Okay.
Thank you.
Please stand here.
Yes.
To prevent or reduce
double chin...
That's what I need.
...look up
and then stretch your neck,
then stick out your chin
to the ceiling like mmm...
Oooh.
And then stick out your tongue
to the ceiling.
Ehh.
And then 10 seconds.
Ehhhhhhh!
You look like a seal.
You literally look like a seal.
[ Laughs ]
I feel younger.
Oh, my God.
Hayashi: Okay.
Last one, let's lift up
the corners of the mouth
a little bit higher.
Smile. Uh‐huh.
And then
stick out your tongue.
Go "Ahh"!
Ahh.
Ahh!
This is not so easy.
Ahh. Ahh!
Show me your puppy.
Koko,
this is not easy.
Ahh.
Ahh!
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
Greiner:
Um, Koko, question.
Yes?
How many hours a day
do you do this?
In general, three to five
minutes per day only.
Corcoran: Wow.
Five minutes?
Because once you learn
how to do those exercises,
you can do it
when you're driving,
walking dog,
or working on computer.
It's easy to continue.
Koko, how many students
do you have?
I have taught
more than 200 people.
I charge $200
for a 1‐hour session.
But, Koko, I'm confused.
It takes five minutes.
Mm‐hmm.
So, what are you doing
with the other
55 minutes?
Oh.
I teach how to do some
specific exercises in detail.
Oh, I see.
Like a seminar?
It's a training seminar.
Seminar, yes.
It's personalized.
In Japan, face exercise has been
very, very popular
over a decade,
so there are many schools,
teachers,
lots of things going on.
Koko, how are you acquiring
your customers?
One of my exciting
revenue stream
is licensing the method
to other instructors.
Have you
done that already,
or are you trying
to do that?
I have two instructors
next to me,
but I'd like
to really scale more.
Are you making any money?
According to you,
this is
a million‐dollar idea, right?
Yes. My lifetime sales
is only $17,000.
♪♪
But with more instructors,
we can do more bigger business.
Hmm.
If you think about
beauty market ‐‐
Botox, filler,
face lift, neck lift ‐‐
$14 billion market in the world.
So you think you're gonna
compete with that head‐on?
Yes.
In Japan,
how popular is Face Yoga?
more than 800 instructors,
Face Yoga instructors.
Wow.
So it's a big business.
It's a big business.
How big is it
in dollars in Japan?
I believe
tens of millions in Japan,
but the Japanese population
is 1/3 of America's.
So we can be bigger, too.
I have another
cosmetics business from Japan
which currently make
half a million annual sales.
What?
So that's
how you're living.
Yes.
You have one business doing
half a million dollars.
Mm‐hmm.
You have the other business
doing $17,000.
Yes.
Shouldn't you maybe
be focusing on the business
that's making you money?
That's a good question,
but I'm entrepreneur.
I always love
doing something new,
and this is really
my passion, as well.
The cosmetics business
is for actually senior market.
Like, 60s, 70s, 80s ‐‐
more mature audience.
Like Kevin.
Because the killer product
is a soap
to eliminate aging body odor.
Body odor?
Body odor associated
with aging.
I want to know
what your next business is.
[ Laughter ]
What's number three?
O'Leary:
If I give you $200,000,
do I get a piece of the
aging body odor business, too?
[ Chuckles ]
No, it's a separate company ‐‐
separate business.
Koko, let me just say,
you're amazing.
Anybody who can get $17,000
from people
for face stretching,
you deserve
a lot of credit.
Thank you.
But there's no easy way
to say this,
but it's just not
a fit for me.
I'm out, Koko.
Okay.
Thank you.
Oza: Koko,
I admire your energy.
It's second to none.
You came
bouncing through there.
But I can't wrap my head
around it, unfortunately.
I'm out.
♪♪
You are
remarkably entertaining.
Truly.
♪♪
I firmly believe
that you'd be hugely successful
if you did
a comedy routine.
♪♪
But on this business,
I'm out.
♪♪
Koko.
Yes?
I think that
in the American market,
people like things fast.
I think that
in the American culture,
I don't think people
will spend all that time a day
doing it
for their face.
I think
they'd go get fillers
and, boom, it's over.
But this is all‐natural,
way affordable
than those medical treatments.
No, I get it.
I get it.
But I just don't see this
working well for me.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
♪♪
Thank you.
Look,
I did the exercises,
I feel
about 20 minutes younger.
[ Laughter ]
What I love
about "Shark Tank"
is I learn something
every day.
Oza:
Every day.
And I've learned about
the aging old‐people odor.
That's a real science.
Greiner: So bad.
Koko, your wonderful energy,
I love it,
but this Face Yoga thing is
really hard to make money off.
It's just ‐‐ you're not
worth $1 million.
I'm just trying
to be pragmatic about it.
I'm out, Koko.
Thank you very much for coming.
Oza: Thank you, Koko.
Cuban:
Congratulations, Koko.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Greiner:
Koko, good luck.
Arigato.
Good luck. Ohh.
Corcoran: I hate to see her go.
She's fabulous.
O'Leary: Look at the back
of that dress. That's crazy.
Cuban:
That's not a dress.
I will be laughing at them when
I become very, very successful,
and if they come to me
at the time,
"Oh, Koko, please teach me
some exercise,"
no!
I will not teach them
any exercise.
[ Laughs ]
So, please leave
with your saggy face.
[ Laughter ]
Narrator:
Next into the Tank
is a special version
of a beloved treat.
♪♪
Hi.
I'm Deborah Torres.
And I'm Jonathan Torres.
We're from
San Jose, California,
seeking $500,000
for 10% of our company...
Atlas Monroe! Atlas Monroe!
Let's cut right
to the chase, Sharks.
We make the best,
most enticing,
extra‐crispy
fried chicken
you've ever
put in your mouths.
But don't take
our words for it, Sharks.
Try it for yourselves
and dig in.
‐Okay.
We don't mind.
Oza:
Fried chicken?
I love me
some fried chicken.
[ Chicken crunching ]
It's good.
Mm‐hmm.
Some of the best fried chicken
you ever had, huh, Sharks?
Very close.
What if we told you
that fried chicken
wasn't chicken at all?
Oh, no [bleep]
Wow.
You heard that right,
Sharks.
We make nothing but 100% vegan,
plant‐based eats
using only organic,
non‐GMO ingredients,
all while satisfying
your every taste bud.
We started this incredible
company from the ground up.
And now our chicken
is an overnight sensation.
But, Sharks,
we need your help
to get our chicken
to food lovers everywhere.
Who wants to cash in
on our chicken?
[ Chuckles ]
The batter
is extremely tasty.
It's got some zip to it.
Thank you.
Thank you!
You really fooled me.
Oza:
Okay, guys.
What are you putting
in the stuff we're eating?
Right now,
our recipe is proprietary.
However, the base of it
is organic wheat.
Organic wheat?
Greiner: Really?
Yes.
So it's not soy?
Not at all.
No.
Now, did you invent all this,
or are you just packaging it all
from other places?
Oh, no, this is 100%
our original recipe.
Everything?
Batter, product, everything?
Everything.
Batter and everything.
We actually
both are the ones
that cook everything
from start to finish.
What's the story?
Well,
a few years ago,
my father was diagnosed
with type 2 diabetes.
My whole family and I
went on
a raw, vegan, and organic diet
for 90 days.
We grew really hangry
at each other...
Very.
...from eating just salads
and fruit salads.
Yep.
We started going to work in
the kitchen and experimenting,
making deliciousness
like raw lasagna and tacos,
and after the 90 days,
he was completely healed.
Wow.
We vowed to stay organic,
plant‐based, and natural.
We continued
to experiment,
and Atlas Monroe
was born.
You manufacture this,
or you have a commercial kitchen
that does it for you,
I assume, by now.
Mm‐hmm.
And your distribution strategy
is what?
So, what we started off first
was with festivals.
We would always have
two‐hour waits,
people were just
so intrigued by our chicken.
So we started
shipping nationwide.
And were you shipping
frozen product?
And how much revenue
are you doing?
Oza:
Oh, sorry, Barbara.
We're shipping frozen,
yeah.
What are
your total sales?
And break it down
by category.
Well, let me tell you guys
something first.
It's never good when
you don't give us the
number. You know that?
Oh, I'm gonna give you
the numbers.
Let me tell you.
[ Laughter ]
We have celebrities,
we have influencers
who vouch for us,
telling the world
that it's the best
that they've ever had
without us ever
paying anyone a dime.
We were the first
and only vegan company
to be invited to the National
Fried Chicken Festival.
That's cool.
Yes.
That is cool.
We were named
Best Fried Chicken.
Out of
all the real chickens?
Yes!
Really?
Of all
the real chickens.
By Time magazine's
"Extra Crispy."
Wow.
From there,
within 24 hours,
we made $12,000 just from
a single Instagram post.
Wow.
We have over 20
wholesale customers
itching to get their hands
on our product...
Well,
it's very exciting...
...comprised of restaurants,
but ‐‐
...but it's translated into what
in sales?
Oza: Drum roll, please.
And the numbers are...
Let me tell you.
I have the best ‐‐
‐What is the revenue?
The revenue is $60,000
that we've done this year.
Okay.
Our net is $73,000,
and our gross
is $76,000.
Wait, wait,
that doesn't add up.
That's confusion.
I think
you got it backwards.
Your total sales are...
No, our total sales
are $60,000.
A lot of our cost
goes into the shipping.
That's why our sales
are $60,000.
Our net,
with shipping and everything,
is $73,000,
and then our gross
is $76,000.
I don't want to stick a pin
in the balloon here, but...
But your numbers
are backwards.
You can't have $60,000 in sales
and make $73,000.
That's impossible.
Including the shipping ‐‐
They're talking about
product revenue
and then shipping revenue.
Yes. Yes.
You've got to include shipping
because you can't go ‐‐
I'm so confused.
Without the shipping ‐‐
Product sales, $60,000.
Yes.
Including shipping revenue,
$73,000.
Yes.
What's your profit
or your loss?
We've made $45,000,
and our expenses is $31,000.
So, we're at
60% profit margin.
When you send out
a typical shipment,
what do you charge
for the chicken,
and what do you pay
for the shipping?
We charge $23
for a six‐piece.
Our average shipping cost
is $21.
Are you charging $44
to the customer?
Yes.
So, now, for the six wings
and any packaging,
what does
it cost you?
It costs us $2.67.
What?!
Per wing
or for six wings?
For six.
Wait a minute.
Six of these giant piece
of fried chicken
cost you $2.60?
And 67 cents.
Oh, my God!
[ Chuckles ]
But asking for $500,000 for 10%
is ludicrous.
A little bit crazy,
yeah.
It's ridiculous.
O'Leary: And so
that would make ‐‐
But the thing is ‐‐
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me finish.
That's the decision
you made, okay?
That's not my decision.
You're not that clear
on your numbers.
Just being honest with you.
But the thing ‐‐
You're not worth $500,000.
I'd have to have
120% of the company.
No, Kevin, you mean
she's not worth $5 million.
I'm saying
she's not worth $500,000.
There's no way to get to
where we need to go with you.
I'm out.
Okay, so...
Thank you.
Deborah, have you tried
to get a co‐packer yet?
We've been hesitant
because it's the only one
of its kind right now.
You don't want to reveal
your secret recipe.
Exactly.
However ‐‐ Exactly.
Speaking of that,
we are currently in talks
with a mega‐famous,
internationally known
fast‐food restaurant chain
that is very interested
in our chicken.
Really?
So they have said
that they would take this?
They actually have our chicken
right now.
Right now.
Are you gonna give them
the recipe?
No.
Okay.
I do want
to tell you guys ‐‐
Before you speak, because I've
been listening very carefully,
I think you're here
way too early.
But what bothers me
is you're confused.
If you were
to come in here
and you had orders
or some proof...
We actually
do have those orders.
We just can't meet the
demand with the space and
the storage that we have.
No, you have the compliments
and the intent,
but you don't
have orders.
No, we have orders.
We have the orders.
We just
tell them, like, "Okay"...
You lack the logistics
to even...
..."you need to wait for
them to be fulfilled right now
because
we're in the process
of fulfilling other orders
currently right now."
Well, I admire
where your heart is,
but for me,
it's just all too confusing.
And you know what?
It's a ridiculous number
you're asking.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Okay, guys,
I'm gonna make you an offer,
but there's gonna be
so many contingencies.
[ Laughs ]
Okay.
Look, I went vegetarian
three months ago,
so this
is important to me,
and I love products
that I can eat.
You're obviously smart.
But you're learning to become
businesspeople as you go.
Every business that goes through
that hyper growth ‐‐
and I've been there ‐‐
if you're not organized
at the bottom,
when you start to grow,
it collapses.
So, I'm gonna give you
the $500K
as a letter of credit,
which means we'll draw down
on it as we grow,
and I want
30% of the business.
♪♪
This is the part
where you say yes.
[ Laughs ]
Oza: So, while you're mulling
Mark's thing,
I wish you had come in with
a little more of a game plan.
I'm just ‐‐ I'm struggling with
the operational setup,
and I think it's just gonna take
a lot of heavy lifting
and at a valuation
that's really too sporty
for me to jump in at.
So, unfortunately,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Okay,
thank you.
What are your projections
for this year and next year?
Well, right now,
like I said,
we do $12,000
in a 24‐hour period of time,
and if we can do that
every single day,
just in the last three months
of this year,
we project
$2.4 million,
just with
the three months.
Next year,
doing $2.4 million each month,
that's $30 million
in a year.
O'Leary: Lori,
what are you doing?
Greiner:
I loved the taste.
I like the space.
I'm super concerned
about what's happening
with eating meat
from the antibiotic problem
and the steroids.
But the problem for me
is that your numbers seem
really impractical.
They're not tangible.
So, unfortunately,
I'm out.
Thank you.
All right.
O'Leary:
But it's not all bad news.
You have an offer
from Mark Cuban.
Maybe he's going to
bring in Rohan.
Contingent on the orders.
All right,
let's hear what they got.
He's replacing my offer,
which he obviously
didn't like.
Oza:
Mark and I ‐‐
I'm back in
'cause Mark sucked me back in.
But here's
what we're thinking.
You need more money,
so we would be willing
to give you guys $1 million.
♪♪
$1 million?
Whoa.
$1 million for everything
you guys have ‐‐
soup to nuts ‐‐ recipes.
We'll give you guys
a 10% royalty on everything.
And we'll do
all the work.
And if these orders are real,
then this is a no‐brainer.
♪♪
You are immediately
a millionaire couple.
Bam.
On top of that,
whatever infrastructure
investments are required ‐‐
kitchen, whatever it is ‐‐
we'll do all that.
You don't have to spend
a nickel.
Listen,
this is an amazing moment
in "Shark Tank" history here.
You came in
with a very confusing pitch.
Now you have
a $1 million offer
by two behemoths
who can actually execute,
and you're still
their partner
because you're getting 10%
in perpetuity.
I mean, I'm stunned.
What are you gonna do?
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Mark and Rohan have offered
$1 million
and a 10% royalty
on all future sales
for Deborah and Jonathan's
plant‐based fried‐chicken
company, Atlas Monroe.
What are you gonna do?
I really like
your original offer.
That's not
on the table anymore.
It's gone.
This is the new offer.
You could've jumped on it right
then, but now it's ‐‐ phew.
Yeah, I ‐‐
O'Leary:
But think about it.
$1 million.
You know how often that happens
in "Shark Tank"?
Are you ready?
Never.
Well, um, I'd like
to come in and say
thank you for your offer,
Mark and Rohan,
but we would like
to decline.
Whoa! Whoa!
Whoa!
Wow.
No, no, please, please.
We really loved
your first offer.
Please don't tell me
you're gonna turn this down.
I was ready to
take your first offer.
You guys are gonna need
a lot of money on this thing.
It's gonna dilute.
Your 30% offer
with the line of credit,
we will show you
that we work
extraordinarily hard.
Really hard.
Guys, honestly,
the million‐dollar offer
is better.
O'Leary:
It's way better.
The money
you're going to have to raise
is going to get you down to 10
with a lot more heavy lifting.
As soon as we get our facility,
we'll fulfill the orders
and we'll get
$1 million immediately.
But you have all the costs
associated with getting there.
That's the challenge.
And the
operational headaches.
I just want to make sure
I'm not in an alternative
universe right here.
[ Laughs ]
Are you turning down $1 million?
Yes or no?
Yes.
Say it ain't so.
It is so.
Everybody in America
wants to be where you are
right now,
and you're gonna walk
out of here without $1 million?
The fact that you guys
are even offering us $1 million
just lets me know
that you guys do understand
what we're worth.
Cuban:
You're right.
No, you're right.
You're exactly right.
But you guys
are gonna take 90% of it.
O'Leary:
I can't take it.
But you got to understand,
we started our company
because we really
don't want to be employees.
You're no different than we are.
I slept on the floor.
Exactly! So you know
the struggle that it takes.
Mustard and ketchup sandwiches.
I know where you're coming from.
Exactly.
We've all had
our backs up against a wall.
Exactly, so...
Guys, I don't think ‐‐
I don't think we have a
meeting of the minds.
We're gonna have to take
the offer back and back out.
Oza:
Yeah, it's ‐‐
I'm sorry.
Unfortunately, guys.
♪♪
Stick a fork in it.
It's over.
♪♪
Greiner:
Good is good,
and good product
always wins in the end.
Thank you.
We're gonna keep working hard.
Thank you. We'll see you guys
on the flip side.
Cuban: For sure.
Good luck.
Keep busting.
Bye.
Deborah: I feel extraordinary,
honestly.
We walked away
from $1 million
and we're walking into
$24 million.
We're probably gonna end up
being sitting right there,
right next to them
pretty soon.
Yeah.
If somebody offers you
$1 million,
you know you have
something really extraordinary
in your hands.
Stand by
what you believe.
There was so much confusion
in that presentation.
Even when you offered her
the million dollars,
she didn't understand it.
Cuban: Yeah, and that's ‐‐
Look, not everybody's
gonna understand
everything about business.
But you have to be honest
with yourself
and be self‐aware
about what you don't know.
♪♪